Hey, Erin! Hey, Beth! Good to see you!
It is so good to see you. Always love podcasting.
Me too.
So I thought what I would like to talk about today is about image corrections. So I know
we've mentioned in a few episodes things about like, you know, measuring only on, you
know, non-transformed images and things like that. That doesn't necessarily mean though
we always want the most raw image possible. We might want to correct our image. And so
I want to talk about illumination correction today because we've also talked about that
in previous episodes where we said like, hey, like sometimes you might want to do a background
correction and things like that, but not really gone into the like when and why and why is
it important. So I wanted to talk about like when are corrections important in general?
When are like, when should you care about these sorts of things and how can we develop
some ideas about that?
Nice.
Yeah, nice to have a, you know, a caveat to the rule that we're like, this is a firm
rule. Always do this. And now a whole episode of Except.
Well, it's always it depends, right? It depends on our pitch raise.
In full disclosure, reasonable people may disagree on some parts here. So big picture
thinking, first of all, it depends what kinds of measurements might we want to make because
when we need to think about, you know, illumination corrections, you know, depends on how important
it is for that particular kind of measurement. And so, you know, when I've tried to come
up this before this list is definitely not exhaustive, you know, you might care about
the number of objects, you might care about the size of the objects, you might care about
their intensity, co-localization, texture, spoiler alert, we definitely plan to do a
co-localization episode at some point, but co-localization, everything's important for
you. But exactly how much you care about certain kinds of precision, which will include like
image correction will depend on what you're measuring. And so I wanted to actually start
with segmentation first because I feel like segmentation is a little bit easier to sort
of think about. So which kinds of measurements rely on having like super accurate, I mean
pixel accurate, obviously you want your segmentation to not be garbage, but in terms of thinking
about which ones rely more or less, and even here we're not, I'm not fully able to say
like for every category, but you know, if all you care about is the count, probably
like pixel accurate segmentation, not super important. If you want to know things like
what are the branching and stuff like having pixel accurate segmentation might be super
important to figure out where branches are. If you want to test the speed of things, if
the things are small, you kind of need to know how much they've moved, which means kind
of need to know where they are. And yeah, I don't know, anything you disagree with here?
No, no, I mean, I think it's, you know, this, we kind of put together this list based on
brainstorm consensus over several different large groups of people chatting through this
very thing. And again, to have sort of end up with the like up arrow, down arrow, it
depends, you know, again, like, as you say, reasonable people can totally disagree on
this. Because even, you know, I love the idea of like here intensity, right? Like, well,
maybe it doesn't matter at all if what your cell boundary is, how perfect that is, if
you're measuring the intensity of a nuclear stain in your cell, right? Because, but if
you're looking very carefully at, you know, something at the very cell membrane, then
oh my gosh, yes, it totally matters if you're off by a pixel or two, because that's, you
know, it's either you have your stain in there or not. And so
if you ever meet Erin in real life, and you find her at a bar somewhere, if you can tell
you some horror stories about how to cell membrane measurements.
Oh my gosh. Yeah, don't get me started or, you know, buy me a beer first because
it's the polite thing to do.
Yeah. Yeah. But I think, I think it certainly does go back to the very root of what we always
say about like, it depends, right? Like, we can't give you a blanket answer for anything.
And so thinking really carefully about what am I trying to do and why am I doing it this way
will give you the answer of how important is X, Y or Z. And, you know, in this case, we're
starting with segmentation, but
And, you know, how much it depends will also depend on the kinds of errors, you know, is
it pixel accurate? Is it, you know, too many things are split too many things are merged?
And again, depending on the kind of measurement that you're making, you know, for tracking
splits and mergers might matter quite a bit more than than some of the other broader categories
like mean intensity, you know, you'll have two objects instead of one or one instead of two,
but the mean might be much less tolerant or much more tolerant.
But there's going to be lots of cases where we get into intensity and I talked about segmentation
first because segmentation is a little bit easier because segmentation because intensity is going
to then also impact segmentation. So when we say intensity errors in our image, like how much do
those, you know, impact things, some of it will impact segmentation. And so there might be, you
know, there's offset on your camera, you know, your camera doesn't literally start at zero.
There is read noise. There is out of focus light that might come from your room, it might come from,
you know, something else that's in your sample, you might have bleed through between your channels.
All of these things might cause intensity errors. The one that as people doing high content screens,
you and I think a lot about Erin is flat field correction and the fact that, you know,
the light is more likely to travel through the center of a lens when we have a non ideal lens
made of glass as opposed to a lens made of physics. Reality gets in the way, unfortunately. Yes.
So things that are at the very edge are less likely to follow this beautiful light plane.
And therefore, our images are actually dimmer and we get this vignetting effect
at the edge rather than, you know, in the middle. And so this is a really common source of intensity
that is correctable, but is something that a lot of times you don't necessarily think about the fact
that, you know, the physics of lenses will cause a cell that sits in the corner to be dimmer than
a cell that sits in the edge. Yeah. And we have one of our original Ask Erin Dearbeth episodes,
one of the very first ones, all about this flat field correction. So if you're like, oh,
that's interesting. Go watch that one. We'll link it in the show notes.
And all of these things are correctable. And generally speaking, we want to correct them
in the order that they happen to our sample. So this is a great cartoon made by a great postdoc,
a step on McGlear, showing if you when you add the background and you add the illumination and
you add the offset, all of these things multiply with each other. And since we know the order that
errors happen, we can remove the errors just sort of by reversing that process and saying if errors
happen one, two, three, we reverse them, you know, in the order of three, two, one. So that, you know,
each we're removing each error before it gets compounded with everything else so that eventually
we get back to the sort of most pure raw image. Yeah. But again, how much should you care about that?
To some degree, it will depend. But if you're a lot of your biology is happening at the edge
of the image, and there's no way to stop that versus if you are taking images of one cell at a
time and you can always center that cell, maybe you care a little bit less. But overall, especially
if the image errors that we're talking about are things like bleed through or things like
your camera offset, you know, if your camera doesn't start at zero, it starts at 200. And
dim signal versus bright signal for you is 300 versus 500. You know, that's going to make a huge
difference because actually it's a difference between one and 300. So you're you're looking at
something that pretends to be a sort of 60% change but is actually a threefold change.
That's huge from the purposes of your metrics. And so if you're thinking about intensity or
especially co-localization, these sorts of image corrections can really matter
for doing these intensity corrections.
Yeah. And I was just going to say again that like, I think,
how am I trying to say this? There are many, you know, many things that we do,
many assays that we run regularly in my lab, like for example, the Cell Painting assay, right,
which we talk a ton about on this podcast, based on that, like that assay, we actually do very
little correction, right? We're not, we don't correct, like we do fly-field correction, but we
don't correct for offsets. We don't, I mean, there's lots of things that we don't do, even though we
are expert image analysts, right? We probably could, could certainly add those into our pipelines,
but our assay readout doesn't need it. So it's extra computation, it's extra,
you know, extra time, extra energy for something that we don't actually need in that assay. We
get plenty of signal without it. Whereas some of the other bespoke pipelines that we end up building
for other kinds of collaborations, we absolutely are thinking about these. So I think it's sort of,
when you see, you see like, oh, here's the things I need to correct and I need to do them in this
order, like that's great to know, absolutely great, like super important to have that conceptually,
but also in the end, kind of like we repeat this a lot too, like what matters is your,
your phenotype that you're reading out. And so if you can get your phenotype nicely read out,
I mean, again, that's sort of what this is saying, you know, for the importance of segmentation,
in that case, the segmentation is the phenotype you're reading out here, the importance of image
correction, you know, in terms of like finding a phenotype, if you don't need to do this,
you don't need to bother. But you very well might. And so,
and it will be hard for you to know if you need to do this, unless you sort of try doing it once
with and without the corrections, and see if it changes. The best way to figure out that you
don't need to do the correction is trying the same thing corrected and uncorrected, and then
seeing, do you need to do the correction? Does it actually change things? But thinking about
what are you trying to measure will, will absolutely sort of help you get there.
Absolutely. Yeah, it's funny. I think people seem to be surprised by how often our answer is,
like, just be empirical about it, try it, right? Like, sure, we can sit here and talk conceptually
about what it should and shouldn't be indefinitely, but, but try it.
Yeah. And what I want to sort of finish by saying is these image corrections will also
affect segmentation. And I've prepped a sort of quick little demo of that and a quick little
demo of the like, but you should just try it and figure out and see how much it changes things.
And to Erin's point about profiling, which I love that she brought up, because for that we are
measuring sort of the average of cases where it matters a ton and things where it really doesn't
matter at all. When we've, when people have looked for profiling at does, in this case,
law field correction matter, the answer is kind of, it kind of matters. So this is a, an image
based profiling as I, it's not Cell Painting, but it's sort of one of the precursor assays to it.
And they showed that they could get 84% accuracy on classification task without doing illumination
correction and they could get 90% with. So like, got better, but it didn't, you know, didn't take
it from 84 to 100. And it was 84 without it. So it absolutely can make a difference. And again,
I'll show you an example of exactly where it makes a difference right here right now. But
I wouldn't necessarily have had any way to predict exactly how much it would be here,
unless somebody tried it out and did it. Yeah.
So I've got here a CellProfilerd pipeline from a data set that if you watch the podcast,
you've seen lots of times before this is BBBC 22. It has, it is a Cell Painting assay.
And it has some little bit wacky illumination. So here's an illumination correction function.
And it's very dark at the edge. And here, these images are scaled such that
the intensity is one at the dimmest point, and then multiples of one beyond that. And I'm seeing
sort of top numbers about 1.6. So a cell that is here versus solid is here that are actually in
sample land, you know, in sample land, these guys are, you know, actually the same intensity
are showing as 60% different in measurement land. But so what I've done here is I've
done cell segmentation three ways. I've done it on the corrected image here.
I've done it. When you've applied, you, you, when you've applied the flat field correction.
When I've applied the flat field correction.
When I haven't applied the flat field correction, and now I start to lose these cells up here.
And I've also added in one where I've changed some of the segmentation settings to intentionally
try to make them worse. And so starting just by looking at what we can see in terms of like
the number of cells that we're finding, the sort of best settings that I validated across a few
different images were I found 100 cells. When I don't do my illumination correction, I get 94
cells. So it is different, but it's not, you know, incredibly super different for this particular
kind of correction. Whereas with this, I get 179. So I having bad segmentation settings in this case
is sort of more perturbed than not doing the corrections. We can actually use CellProfilers
workspace viewer to take a look at what this looks like in terms of like where the cell settings are.
And so if we look at the just the uncorrected, there's nothing up here at all in this whole top
region is getting like very like weird and sparse. Whereas we're doing a much better job up there
when we actually have correction and the correction is sort of bringing all of those cells back.
When we have bad settings, we then have some sort of like weird tiny objects and things like that.
And this wasn't a case where the cell segmentation was doing a particularly great job compared to
those a couple of others that I demoed it with. But we can definitely it definitely gets worse
in the other settings. And we can see the segmentation parameter choice. In this case,
is affected also by our illumination correction. So these things have to be evaluated together.
We lose some cells, we lose six out of our hundred cells when our illumination isn't corrected.
And it's going to sort of interact with our overall segmentation settings too.
And one of the nice things with CellProfiler is we can also look directly at things like the
intensity distribution that's measured. And so here I've used CellProfiler as measure object
intensity distribution module to say in the corrected image for the the real cells versus
the uncorrected image for the cells that are segmented also in the uncorrected image,
how much of the intensity is sort of present in the inside versus the outside of the cell.
And again, one of the first things that you'll probably notice is just the cell segmentations
are different. And that's going to drive some of the differences that we see at a measurement
level because here we're seeing a really dark color, which means this is the outside bin of a
lot of the cells because these cells have just gotten big being sort of marked as oh these cells
have all of their intensity concentrated at the edge. And that's kind of not true. It's just that
these cells are sort of like making weird shapes. And so therefore it's messing with our ability to
sort of say is the cell intensity at the center or at the edge. But even in cases where we we do have
a cell that's in both places again like how accurate we can get those boundaries and how
dark it says like those outside things are
really can be pretty different. Again, maybe enough to matter, maybe not. But if we look up here,
here this cell is present in both places. And it says that the outside bin of the cell has 50%
of the intensity here. But it has 70% of the intensity here. Because the outside bin of the
cell is not drawn correctly. And because you know the intensity hasn't been corrected. So 50% versus
70% you might come to a very different conclusion about like whether the cell has all of its intensity
in the center or in the edge. So for an intensity measurement having this correction like makes a
huge difference both to our segmentation but also to our ability to just do good measurements
even when the segmentation is right. Yeah. That's an awesome example. And then I think
to take it one step further if we think about
the experiment as a whole. So as we've zoomed in in the corner here and if this was our whole
population of cells, we would probably whatever our readout is, with this readout in particular
that you're showing be getting really different answers in terms of whatever our biological task
was, whether it was counting things at a single cell level or categorizing ourselves or whatever.
But maybe if you know so again if this is really happening in just this one
region and we have all of the cells in the rest of the image are unaffected,
like maybe this will sort of math out in the wash, which is often what we talk about in
sort of our profile like as you mentioned like in our profiling assays where we have so many cells,
it doesn't matter if a small fraction of them have not super accurate measurements because
it will also convene around a nice median and we're looking at the median of a huge population.
But here if you're looking at sort of single cell distribution, that may matter a whole lot.
So again like thinking your very most downstream task, what are you doing?
Yeah and we can look here because CellProfiler reports the per image means. So if we compare the
top four rows to the bottom four rows, it goes 0388 versus 0385 pretty close.
1,345, 1,335 again pretty close. 0277 versus 0275 pretty close and 5502 versus 5533. So again we
haven't really changed anything past like until we get to the third decimal point. We're pretty close
but you know if we're looking for really small changes maybe that amount makes a difference,
maybe it doesn't.
Yeah so that was all I wanted to say about corrections. When do you do them? How do you
decide if you want to do them? But I do think Erin's advice of just try doing it and see.
Like see if it makes a difference. If you can do, if you don't have to do all of those corrections,
they're never bad to do but they will, you might have to measure some of them, you might have to
like take die slides and doing that and some of them may be impossible to do depending on your setup.
You know if you want to measure changes in sort of intensity over the course of a plate without
how you can't do that without being able to sort of take the plate off and put it back and then
you're not, that may have been more perturbative than you know just not doing that correction in
the first place. But you can see certainly some cases where in subtle change in some ways it will
make subtle changes that you can tell whether or not they affect your ability to measure your biology.
Again let's do the catchphrase. It depends. But hopefully this gives you some ways to think about
corrections when we do them, why we do them, and when they might be important for you.
Awesome thanks Bop. Yeah thanks for having me. Bye.